c'est un petit bout de plage qui est au
centre d'une bagarre de chef
d'entreprise
nous sommes à batelière et depuis ce
matin plus personne n'a théoriquement le
droit d'occuper cet espace c'est le
domaine public maritime
l'autorisation d'occupation temporaire
aot t est arrivé à expiration
les propriétaires de l'actuelle lilies
pourrait bien être priés de faire leurs
bagages
ça fait plus de onze ans qu'on exploite
en bon père de famille ce restaurant il
ya une super solidarité avec avec les
salariés et le danger effectivement
c'est qu'est l'hôtel batelière souhaite
qui d'ailleurs en difficulté financière
souhaite reprendre le fruit de 10 ans de
sueur et de travail acharné pour en
faire ce que le lise est aujourd'hui
nous ne pouvons pas reprendre ce qui est
déjà à nous répondre de leur côté les
dirigeants de l'hôtel batelière juste
ici les propriétaires du lilies étaient
des sous traitants de l'hôtel mais la
loi ne permet plus de sous traiter les a
ôté dans la maison ils pas occupé à
défendre
[Musique]
revendiquant 350 couverts par jour
les propriétaires du lily se sentent
victimes d'une injustice
ils mettent en avant leurs 45 salariés
qui craignent pour leur emploi
ce que nous souhaitons c'est de garder
la haute et et que nous puissions
continuer notre notre travail
tranquillement sereinement
et voilà vous avez pas envie de changer
de propriétaire ah non pas du tout ça ça
nous a jamais effleuré l'esprit nous
voulons garder nos dirigeants parce que
ça fonctionne très bien avec eux donc du
coup on vois pas pour quelle raison
devrait changer le groupe monplaisir qui
possède l'hôtel batelière dit s'engager
à reprendre tous les salariés
les propriétaires du lys disent leur
volonté de négocier pour trouver un
terrain d'entente
c'est au final l'état qui tranchera en
attribuant à l'un ou l'autre la fameuse
autorisation d'occupation à la mi
janvier